junge alte gestiegener bisherigen arge
platz im kopf oder so
zwei mitstreiter einmal mit profis oder
so weit her ist doch weil doch eine
spitzen anlage bei mir ist die touch
ausgerastet vorfreude rückgrat in der
findungsphase leute also vertrieb dem
schnitzen ja herzlich willkommen
er war der stürmer für den die tour wird
die woche
es gibt immer die woche ich habe eine
arche überbieten
ich will gerade einfällt
ok freue mich ich felders praxis aber
nach aber ich brauch mal endlich was zu
essen ich mache das man insgesamt eine
eigene fahren jetzt auch schon gemacht
werde ich sie gerade interesse an meine
farben da ist nichts drauf
die hühner müssen dass die mit seinen
spaß haben jetzt weihnachten eher
weniger sahen da habe ich eh genug daran
in meinem namen sagt habe ich alles voll
zu töten
er wohnt in diesem scheiss haus lege was
los
die city cobblestone gebilde bis kubica
so des kev was der weihnachtsmann
fokussiert mehr und er hat ein schlimmer
gemacht
dabei war die chinesin den den de
krasser daher dabei ordentlich auch
abgepflückt will und ich habe zwar noch
fix gezeigt hatte mit seinen mit seinem
schnee fahren voll von der deponie ist
also meinst du nicht er ich bin ein
genie immer meine meine spieler letzten
folge wo ich natürlich nicht gestorben
also ich war mal ganz kurz
ach so ja klar game an
ich sag mal ganz gemeine zuschauer und
zwar bin ich derzeit produzieren weil
ich vom 21 bis 28
das heißt auch über den 24 das heißt
jetzt werden folgen vorproduziert das
heißt wenn ihr rein theoretisch in einem
der anlieger auch wenn ihr rein
theoretisch in einem in einer folge der
anderen teilnehmern heitz mal irgendwie
etwas sehen sollte was ihr denkt das
haben wir noch gar nicht erreicht werde
das haben wir noch gar nicht konkreter
gewinnen einfach abwarten dann rede ich
jetzt mal wieder einfach abwarten und
dann dieses deutsch mir peinlich einfach
abwarten und dann kommt das wieder meine
fahrzeugsteuer die briten halten dann
kommt das auch bei mir immer der folge
nicht mehr produzieren das ist unser
massen projekt ein bisschen schlecht
aber dass heute nur kurz sagen jetzt zu
staffeln wie gehts dankeschön
luca wir sind ihr außen am außenposten
und ok wehrleiter euch da hinten
godzilla macht es dunkel
ok wo man im moment ich glaube weg nach
vorne
okay wir sind zurück im studio hier in
michael fried unser außen-reporter sturm
waffe lp ist wohl umgekommen
wir erreichen jetzt mal einfach selber
ich möchte meine schaufel machen aber
ich hab einfach keine sachen na ja
bereits etwa selbst ins krisengebiet zum
herrn dr sturm waffel okay wenn mich
verbindet dich
wo bist du so willst du die verwendung
besser an richtiger weg gehen rede
gewesen
du hast du hast du dich nicht du auch ja
aber nur halb ich bin die letzte folge
einfach so ekelhaft gestorbene herrlich
hat lediglich 26 eisen oder so bin ich
sogar 5000 oder so hilft und was sollte
der weihnachtsmann zu weihnachten
schenken 53 millionen euro
d d d d d d d d d
die sechs punkte die wollen irgendwie zu
mir komm bekommt spd habe ich vielleicht
dass dirk schwerd gehabt die konnte ich
mir signale mlg pro a
wir wünschen dass das projekt war kein
pvp ihr wisst den oder hochspringer bist
bei mir gnade platz im kopf oder so echt
ich habe mich richtig richtig nennen das
video aber geplatzt in meinem kopf viele
klicks denken junge ist hat mich richtig
habe mir direkt an den kopf gefasst so
wehgetan echt fläche etwas kaputt
gegangen
die mal schnell zum arzt zu werden die
feuerwehrleute wenn ich das gefallen
hatten lukas ich mehr verletzten sollen
in den nächsten folgen das auf jeden
fall die daumen nach oben mit mehr
verletzen das tut richtig weh alter
hatte da schon war das irgendwie wenige
stehen habt ihr da so dass da irgendwie
was geplatzt oder hoch kommt nur eine
jazz von dir hier nur den zweck nicht
die liegt auf dem dach
ich wollte hier so schön diese folge
weißt du wollte ich meinen meinen
schritt hier ausbauen
bei der ist alles weg und ich hab das
aufs dach gelegt weil zumindest aufs
dach die jazz hier bestehe
ja es stimmt die sachen fliesen runter
immer treppen
ganz ehrlich da schon oder so so cook
effekt minecraft fraktion in kraft
ein schuss gefallen aber ich glaub das
war deiner eisen ein scheres kann sein
tatsächlich ich brauche kann ich mir
rein theoretisch ein bild von dir nehme
ich glaube ich kenne
du hast es war auf jeden fall so dass
ich halt gestorben bin und ich hatte so
viele sachen und ich hatte alles dabei
man jemanden schwert und alles und ich
habe als einziger noch keine diamanten
dem projekt gefunden ich auch nicht ob
ich halte die sachen von kef nicht
erhöhte untermiete studieren weil den
kev ein netbook typisch so hasst
eventuell noch verbrauchen oder so
weil das dorf dass jeder gestorben ist
auch das habe ich nicht das muss zu
haben ich habe keinen ball zur mitte wo
ernsthaft nicht was ich habe irgendwie
ich hab' ich hatte 40 weizen oder so das
habe ich nicht nehmen
okay das empfehlen darüber die
kartoffeln abzubauen es geht sowieso
besser also dann bist du schneller mehr
geld muss erst mal was kann ich dann
eventuell abbauen was hab ich dann
gesagt das iglu ist ein halbes kilo
geworden
die gui blieb nur das passt noch zu
weihnachten
wir empfehlen eine schlittschuhbahn aber
dafür brauchen eine spitzhacke wir dann
macht sich hier ist des weiteren gibt es
übrigens hier
wo bist du denn hier liegt ja ich hab
den gefunden
ich habe gemerkt hat hellwinkel ausnahme
dass auch ohne hast du staffing denken
entschuldigung und weiter bauen möchte
eine hacke und diese hacke muss ich mir
jetzt alles aus bruchstein machen weil
ich kein eisen hab ich bin zu arm für
die chance ist scheiße zurück das ist
ich habe auch meine jobs kriegen nachher
heute abend auch im business ist die
erste ausschluss machen und eventuell
werde ich da auch das ein oder andere
easter egg einbauen
denn selbst wenn ihr nämlich die wellen
namen habe ich runter lautet dass ihr
euch dann denkt die stadt hatte in der
folge nicht gezeigt an einem strand
gefunden oder schon dann bräuchte also
das mache ich mache schilder irgendwo in
dieser welt und steht
easter egg von luca toll punkt und dann
ein wort und wenn wir all diese wörter
nach er zeigen kann
am ende des projekts nämlich außer kann
der ist der king des lebens in dem
westring im ringen im business im
business ring oder auch stoffels dingen
dann längeren spitzen gegenstand meine
ich bin nun spitzen gegenstand aber das
ist richtig cool welcher kohle dutt hat
eigentlich diese ganzen gartenbau mehr
angeflogen als bereich dieser quadcopter
ich weiß ja dich kann ich kann ich nur
gehört das war ein cooler ok schade aber
es ist halt ex trainer wir hatten in der
ganzen umgebung nach die drei kein
einziges auto damit einfach mal
losgezogen erfolg und habe ganz viel
setzen mitgenommen dass sie als
angepflanzt zwischen auto und geiler
baut damit die tabelle der rundeste mir
für dich so viel gut
er stirbt lassen bittet mich damit so
ich fand es natürlich auch nachhaltiger
mensch ich habe nur weil wir davor
wieder gesungen haben das nicht gut
programmierung viele viele machen das ja
immer vor den aufnahmen ist die zeche
sich ein singen
ich heiße jedoch nicht mal die zähne
form öffnen
es hat wirklich so ich war sicher seid
ihr noch nie gemacht bei mir das macht
der abnehmer hat er mir damals gesagt
ich denke einfach nur so weil es ein
geheimnis was nicht ist
nein das ist sogar ethisch oder so er
wird als kritisch in den folgenden
keiner einfach so ein bisschen besser
reden und das ist generell muss sterben
gleich irgendwann wieder vorbei aber ich
möchte etwas schaffen ausstrecken
ich wollte auf jeden fall mein dingsda
und gefährlich machen
allerdings hätte ich darum wird es nacht
wird gepennt und dann auf den fall reden
kann ja noch ein bisschen formen formen
ersetzen wenn ich ein paar schöne
steinchen für steinchen salon
ddp was habt ihr denn gesungen doch mal
am anfang
das haben wir gezogen
meine nein ich hätte gerne ähnlich ich
kenne ja irgendwie nur dieses lied
nahezu du kannst auch noch andere und
beister das ach das ist bei der das ist
nicht okay okay ich war letzter zeit
relativ viel rolf zuckowski auf jeden
fall weil der mich auf jeden fall auch
an spricht von einer musik ja ist auch
er kenne ich auch immer wieder in ihren
auszug auf ski ja da muss ich auch war
so in deinem deinem aussehen so stark
der ausdruck sei das ist schon einiges
komplett unter zusammen also von rolf
zuckowski touristen habe ich das jetzt
kompliment oder als beleidigung sehen
soll
das nicht gut wo bist du ich hätte mein
haus im blick micha ich wurde schon
wieder voll in skelett abgeschossen
diese hohen dinge betrifft die ganze
zeit verzauberten
okay gut er mach dir mal der beleidigung
aller nicht nur ein paar beleidigung
jupiters wenn euch die perfekte kag
folge gefallen haben könnte gerne lassen
wenn es die folge eines gefechts
verfallen hat dann seid ihr nicht
weggeht richtig merkwürdig drauf und
kann vor 3006 ihr verzichten fast die
beleidigung zu ende
um bei 4.000 kraft zeigte er den
nächsten folgen sein ellbogen ja ok
besten gefallen hat dann würde ich mich
auch um eine bewertung freuen balkon
kraft vorbei sagt man nichts mit kommt
mal wieder klar fall live und dann
kommen wir ohne form von dem album balm
ich okay malerei neu rostowski roskosmos